Oh, it's my wife.
You got to answer this for me.
Tell her I'm not here.
I can't do that.
Tell her we're working late.
We don't work together.
Tell her you cast me on a movie.
A movie?
Do you even act?
What kind of part would you play?
I don't know, leading man?
I don't see you as the leading man type.
Wait, how about a hard-boiled police detective with a chip on his shoulder?
Fine.
Or no, I've got it.
A quiet bus driver with a shady past he keeps to himself...
...until one day he has to stand up for what he believes in.
Answer it!
No, no, I've got it.
A former basketball star who saves his alma mater from the wrecking ball...
...by doing the one other thing he loves: party clown.
No!
An ex-basketball star who's abducted by aliens...
...and leads a ragtag team of Martians to the intergalactic championship!
Give me that phone.
Charles, give me that phone.